dass seine patientin die die mutation
b17 nachgewiesen bekommen hat deshalb
sind alle etwas in hab-acht-stellung
großes risiko sind immer die ganzen
schläuche die in dem patienten stecken
ja da darf natürlich nichts rausreißen
wir dürfen ihn aber auch nicht darin
einwickeln das davor unter den patienten
nachher nichts liegen ganz großes
augenmerk wird immer auf den
beatmungsschlauch natürlich gelegt jetzt
merkt schon dass der patient wieder
beginnt schneller zu atmen was über die
dauer für ihn zu anstrengend wäre
ich ertrage mich ja nicht ungeschminkt
also vor allem auch der lippenstift das
sind so automatismen irgendwie das sieht
ja eh keiner mit der maske nahe
fleißigen habt ihr denn heute ich mag
essen für die kinder
17.45 muss ich los zum dienst müssen sie
die zeit online verbringen mussten zu
hause bist musst du sie lieben wenn ich
auf arbeit bin bin ich häufig mit dem
kopf bei meinen kindern also ich muss
auch bestehen und das gebe ich offen zu
als mutter ich habe auch immer mein
handy in der casag tasche einfach wenn
sie in der schule sind
zumal der hort an eine kopfplatzwunde
hat oder dem geschlecht im haus abgeholt
werden ich bin schon viel mit dem kopf
auch bei meinen kindern
[Musik]
war ja mein name ist niveaulos ich bin
41 jahre alt und seit 16 jahren in dem
diese krankenschwester seit november bin
ich im rahmen der pandemie im cca
eingesetzt das ist eine spezielle klinik
die eingerichtet wurde für kobe
patienten intensiv flüchtige kuh wie
patienten
guten morgen guten morgen
wenn sie mich verstehen schließen sie
mal die augen
wir reden mit jedem patienten egal wie
tief schlafend erscheint das schlimmste
was man sich vorstellen kann wäre wenn
niemand mit uns spricht über tage
vielleicht sogar wochen
ich gucke jetzt einmal ob der patient
ansprechbar ist und versuche ihm eine
adäquate reaktion abzuringen
dass wir nicht so richtig gelungen ist
jetzt den patienten habe ich vor zwei
wochen tatsächlich in einem spät ins mit
aufgenommen weil der patient noch nicht
beatmet der war war es mitte 50 hat in
der vorgeschichte eine form des
blutkrebs und hat sich jetzt eben noch
krone eingefangen und hat tatsächlich
dieses volle krankheitsbild kobe 19
ausgebildet so super habe ich den
nächsten tag im spätdienst und da war
der patient schon koma und beatmet und
lag auch schon direkt auf dem bauch
jetzt ist es zwei wochen später an dem
patient ist immer noch beatmet was
natürlich nicht so erfreulich ist
andererseits konnte man auch kann man
auch sehen dass er sich stabilisiert hat
und wird sogar auf dem weg sind
die schlafmittel wieder ein bisschen zu
reduzieren so dass wir
hoffentlich bald den beatmungsschlauch
entfernen können
vielleicht sogar das war das tagesziel
oder ist das tagesziel dem tourbus zu
entfernen
dann schaue ich mir das beatmungsgerät
an das kann ich hier nochmal mini
schauen wie viel prozent von minuten
volumen er schon spontan atmet noch
ausbaufähig
[Applaus]
wenn ich morgens meinen patienten
übernehmen
dann setze ich mir meistens zu tages
ziehen und zwar fällt es mir dadurch
leichter die aufgaben über den tag
besser zu priorisieren so dass ich mein
ziel nicht aus den augen verlieren
[Musik]
das ist eine patientin die die mutation
bei 117 nachgewiesen bekommen hat und
wir deshalb noch mal besonders
vorsichtig sind ja und hoffen dass sie
sich nicht vermehrt hierdurch genau
deshalb müssen wir noch mehr darauf
achten
aber mehr geht ja eigentlich schon nicht
mehr als wir machen ja alles was geht
deshalb sind alle etwas in
hab-acht-stellung die auslagerung ist
ein ganz spezielles manöver also wir
drehen ja den patienten tatsächlich 180
grad um seine eigene achse
das ist nicht so einfach also ich sag
mal bei einem recht normalgewichtigen
patienten brauchen wir dazu vier
pflegekräfte und ein arzt und ja umso
schwerer der patient umso mehr personal
braucht man dann auch wenn man es
einfach da nicht mehr schafft diesen
menschen auf diese kissen zu heben
großes risiko sind immer die ganzen
schläuche die in dem patienten stecken
die ganzen zugänge katheter drainagen da
darf natürlich nichts rausreißen wir
dürfen ihn aber auch nicht drin
einwickeln ist dafür unter dem patienten
nachher nichts liegen
er würde sofort druckstellen davon
bekommen und ganz großes augenmerk wird
immer auf den wartungs schlauch
natürlich gelegt der arzt oder die
ärztin stehen am kopfende und halten den
beatmungsschlauch wer ist beim drehen
weil es immer ja die größte angst von
allen ist
meine gedanken sind die ganze zeit bei
meinen mäusen zu hause die seit heute
morgen alleine sind eigentlich ganz viel
denken muss ich glaube die werden
eigentlich ganz froh wenn sie eine mutti
hätten im home-office zurzeit oder ein
papa ja so ist es leider nicht
jetzt habe ich den ersten schritt getan
und zwar habe ich ihnen von einer
kontrollierten beatmungs formen eine
beatmungs form umgestellt am
beatmungsgerät in der er selber mehr
leisten muss sozusagen der atem arbeit
verrichtet zum training
jetzt merkt man schon dass platzieren
wiederbeginn schneller zu atmen was über
die dauer für ihn zu anstrengend wäre
gestern habe ich mit einer freundin
telefoniert und sie hat mir erzählt dass
sie eine arbeitskollegin hat mit der sie
ins gespräch kamen über corona für thema
überall
und dann hat sie mir erzählt dass ihre
kollegin sich tatsächlich als crooner
leutner entpuppt hat und
sie meine freundin bekehren wollte und
dann hat mich meine freundin gefragt was
sie so leuten sagen soll
dann hatte ich ad hoc auch überhaupt
keine antworten da muss jetzt darüber
nachdenken und nicht beschäftigt mich
jetzt schon den ganzen tag und letztlich
bin ich zu dem ergebnis gekommen dass
ich denke dass so eine diskussion
überhaupt gar keinen sinn macht in
meinen augen es ist eine ganz
persönliche meinung so diese menschen
fernab von jedem wissenschaftlichen
verständnis und jeder realität die leute
haben in meinen augen auch keine
plattform verdient keinen medienrummel
oder sonst irgendwelche es aussehen in
meinen augen sind das alles haltlose
emotionale reaktion und haltung
[Musik]
jetzt kontrolliere ich eben ob ich
erfolg hatte mit dem wieder umstellen
die kontrollierte beatmungs form der
weitaus ruhigere atmung also das muss
jetzt erstmal so lassen wir können als
trainingseffekt das zwischendurch
weitermachen aber dauerhaft scheint das
noch nicht zu schaffen
selbstständig komplett zu atmen so zu
sagen dass unser tagesziel dahin
schwindet wahrscheinlich mir dass er
noch ein bisschen mehr zeit braucht
[Musik]
wenn ihr einen einblick haben wollten
den alltag an der charité und dem
deutschen herzzentrum dann schaut doch
mal rein in unsere neue serie herz und
nieren
die zdf mediathek
[Musik]